[Música]
hola soy natalia cabrera y les doy la
bienvenida aquí a américa el espacio de
france 24 para revisar en profundidad
las noticias e historias de nuestro
continente y esto es lo que veremos hoy
vamos primero a centroamérica a honduras
a hablar de la caída en desgracia del
recién salido del cargo el ex presidente
juan orlando hernández quien se entregó
a la policía que tenía un riguroso
dispositivo de seguridad en las afueras
de su casa luego de que eeuu no
solicitar en la extradición por delitos
asociados al narcotráfico y la
corrupción
luego visitamos el norte del continente
primero canadá donde la ley de
emergencia activada por el primer
ministro justin crudo ayuda a reabrir el
puente ambassador que conecta a la
nación con eeuu y permitió además los
primeros arrestos en ottawa donde el
movimiento de protesta en rechazo a la
vacuna obligatoria se mantenía pese a
que se trata de una minoría de los
canadienses
y terminamos en mexico para conocer la
historia de como los habitantes de la
península de yucatán intentan rescatar
un deporte ancestral maya que dejó de
jugarse hace más de 500 años
y comenzamos en honduras con la
dramática caída del expresidente juan
orlando hernández que salió de su casa a
entregarse a la policía que rodeaba su
hogar horas luego de que eeuu lo
solicitará en extradición por cargos
relacionados con el narcotráfico el
porte de armas y la corrupción
señalamientos que el ex mandatario de
derechas siempre ha negado con especial
vehemencia luego de que una corte de
nueva york- condenara a su hermano tony
por traficar drogas a eeuu como llegan
estas bandas delincuenciales a las
esferas más altas del poder en honduras
les contamos en el siguiente informe
en una caída en desgracia de película el
hombre que gobernó honduras durante
cuatro años se entregó a la policía
el arresto llegó menos de un mes después
de que se llamara castrol o reemplazar
en el cargo más importante de honduras
la primera presidenta del país
centroamericano llegó al poder jurando
que terminaría con la que calificó de
narco dictadura corrupta
honduras
en
estos últimos 12 años
y lo recibo el manjar
[Música]
el nuevo gobierno fue rápido en
responder a la solicitud de extradición
de eeuu washington acusa a juan orlando
hernández de facilitar el narcotráfico y
usar los miles de millones de dólares
que recibió en sobornos para financiar
su campaña algo que él siempre negó me
resulta
increíble
que los testimonios falsos de asesinos
confesos se han escuchado de valorados
de esa forma
el pedido de extradición llegó después
de que se revelara que se le retiró su
visado a la unión americana por estar en
una lista de personajes señalados de
narcotráfico y corrupción desde julio de
[Aplausos]
un giro de 180 grados en la relación que
hernández tenía con la casa blanca
cuando llegó al poder a tras el golpe de
estado en el que fue derrocado manuel
zelaya esposo de la actual mandataria
entonces hernández era un aliado del
presidente obama pero desde hace al
menos diez años la administración de
control de drogas la dea por sus siglas
en inglés ha estado construyendo el caso
en su contra
investigaciones que revelan que el ex
jefe del cártel de sinaloa el mexicano
joaquín el chapo guzmán le dio un millón
de dólares en efectivo a juan antonio
tony hernández el hermano del ex
mandatario para financiar su campaña
desde entonces según eeuu facilitó el
tráfico de drogas provenientes de
colombia y venezuela hacia el norte del
continente
tony hernández fue condenado en 2021 a
cadena perpetua por una corte de
manhattan la misma que condenó a el
chapo y que probablemente llevaría el
proceso del exmandatario cuando su
extradición sea avalada por la justicia
hondureña
y mientras tanto el presidente de
guatemala alejandro giammattei está
siendo salpicado por denuncias de
corrupción un testigo protegido reveló
que funcionarios recibieron un supuesto
pago de más de 2 millones de dólares
obtenidos a través de contratos ilícitos
con empresas constructoras para la
campaña de la segunda vuelta
presidencial de 2019 que no fue
declarado a las autoridades el gobierno
negó los señalamientos
y vamos ahora a eeuu para revisar la
cifra de la semana 73 millones esa es la
cantidad en dólares que debe pagar la
compañía fabricante de armas remington a
los familiares de las víctimas de la
masacre de sandy hook en connecticut que
ocurrió cuando un hombre entró a una
escuela primaria usando un rifle de esa
marca y disparó a matar a 20 niños y
seis adultos la empresa ahora en
bancarrota acudir a aseguradoras para
pagar la histórica cifra a nueve
familias es la primera vez que un
fabricante de armas llega a un acuerdo
por una demanda en un tiroteo masivo en
la unión americana el caso se enfocó en
que el rifle buscaba atraer a hombres
jóvenes a través de anuncios
publicitarios y videojuegos violentos
pero para los padres de las víctimas esa
justicia legal no es suficiente
amigos sistemas que ves nuestro sistema
legal nos ha dado algo de justicia pero
como le dije al abogado georges cof cof
hace unas semanas
de bernardo never had to justice
nunca vamos a tener una justicia
verdadera la justicia verdadera sería
tener a nuestro hijo de 15 años aquí
junto a nosotros pero ven y nunca tendrá
15 en abertis testing
ahora hagamos una parada en sudamérica
para revisar otras noticias del
continente esta semana más de 100
personas perdieron la vida en los
deslizamientos e inundaciones generados
por las intensas lluvias registradas en
la ciudad brasileña de petrópolis
ubicada en el estado de río de janeiro
no es la primera vez que un desastre de
estas características ocurre en la zona
ya en 2011 más de 900 personas murieron
allí en petrópolis y en teresópolis por
lo que hay críticas a las autoridades
por no haber reubicado a los habitantes
de la región
y la asamblea nacional de ecuador
reglamento del aborto en caso de
violación tarea que le había sido
encargada por la corte suprema de
justicia tras su aprobación en 2021 la
medida permite la interrupción del
embarazo hasta la semana número 12 en el
caso de mujeres mayores de edad que
habiten en ciudades y hasta la semana 18
en menores de edad o en mujeres que
habiten en zonas rurales
y murió a los 93 años cristina calderón
la última hablante nativa de la lengua y
hagan una etnia que habita en el extremo
sur de chile su muerte representa la
pérdida de una parte importante de la
memoria cultural chilena su familia y
los habitantes de la villa chica la
recuerdan como una ferviente promotora
de la conservación de su cultura
ancestral
y a partir del 28 de febrero canadá
flexibiliza sus requisitos de entrada
para viajeros internacionales mientras
estén vacunados los visitantes podrán
ingresar al país con una prueba de
antígenos y no con una pc r como se
requería antes el anuncio llegó al mismo
tiempo que los camioneros que están
bloqueando la capital ottawa mostraron
no querer dar un paso al costado y
continuar su protesta a pesar de la
activación de la ley de emergencia por
parte del primer ministro justin crudo
que le dio a la policía poderes para
tratar de dispersarlos y que permitió
los primeros arrestos este mismo viernes
termina uno de los bloqueos en canadá
con esta vía de albert está abierta al
tráfico y otros siguen a medida que la
policía avanza sobre los manifestantes
que permanecían la vía principal que
conecta la ciudad de windsor con dicho
hoy en eeuu reabrió también por allí
pasa un cuarto del comercio entre ambas
naciones pero en la capital ottawa la
historia fue diferente con camioneros
manifestándose y ocupando vías en la
ciudad por varias semanas exigen ponerle
fin al mandato de vacunas contra el
joven 19 necesarias para cruzar la
frontera entre otras medidas sanitarias
y expresan su ira contra el gobierno de
jeaustin crudo
hay muchos juegos sucios yo espero que
podamos darle un giro porque es demente
lo que están haciendo ya no representan
a los canadienses y se olvidan
completamente de propósito de la razón
por la que están ahí trabajan para la
gente no contra la gente
la semana vio la renuncia del jefe de la
policía de ottawa en medio de serios
cuestionamientos de su manejo de la
crisis con el fin de darles a las
autoridades locales libertad para actuar
todo la ley de emergencia convirtiéndose
en el segundo mandatario en la historia
canadiense en hacerlo en un acalorado
debate en el parlamento defendió su
decisión estas medidas deben cumplir y
van a cumplir la carta de derechos y
libertades siempre vamos a defender los
derechos de los canadienses a la reunión
pacífica para fue la libertad de
expresión pero los bloqueos deben
terminar una meta difícil para todo
mientras algunas provincias se suman al
descontento con la vacuna obligatoria
pese a que el 80% de los canadienses
están vacunados
y vamos a finalizar nuestro recorrido
por las américas en méxico en un país
donde el fútbol es super popular un
grupo de niños le apuesta a un deporte
ancestral el poct apoc un juego de
pelota que practicaban los mayas de la
península de yucatán y es que es
probablemente el deporte más antiguo del
mundo como nos lo cuenta nuestra
corresponsal katia espinoza en el
siguiente informe con sus rostros y
cuerpos pintados estos pequeños se van
transformando en auténticos guerreros
mayas así practican el pop está pop o
juego de pelota maya tienen entre 7 y 12
años de edad y buscan rescatar este
deporte ancestral que fue importante
para los mayas y que dejó de jugarse
hace más de 500 años porque es un juego
que jugaban nuestros abuelos tatarabuelo
en hace miles de años pero ese deporte
se perdió por un largo tiempo impulse
ahorita se está renovando de nuevo
impuso quise jugar y estaba muy bonita
y
el sonido del caracol marca el inicio
del juego cada equipo se compone de un
mínimo de dos a un máximo de cinco
jugadores que intentarán pasar la pelota
al otro lado de la cancha y cruzar esta
pelota por el aro usando únicamente la
cadera la técnica le enseña josé
manrique quien hace menos de una década
decidió reactivar este juego de pelota
cuando era de la modalidad de cadera se
usaron una pelota de 3 kilos un poquito
menos un poquito más y cuando era de la
modalidad de antebrazo una pelota de
hule compacto de 600 a 700 gramos el
juego de pelota fue parte fundamental en
la cultura maya y es quizá el deporte
por equipo más antiguo del mundo con más
de 2500 años el campo de juego más
grande y conocido se encuentra en
chichén itzá mide más de 170 metros de
largo por 70 de ancho en un país donde
el fútbol y el béisbol son deportes
estrellas pequeños como jose le apuestan
a preservar un bien intangible de sus
antepasados
porque ese deporte se perdió por varios
años y quiero que la gente se meta al
club a jugar para que el deporte sea
grande surja una iniciativa que hoy ha
dado frutos desde el 2015 se disputa la
copa mundial de este deporte y cada vez
más niños y jóvenes se lanzan a la
batalla
y gracias por acompañarnos en esta
emisión de aquí américa en la producción
estuvo luis fernando montes pueden
seguirme en redes sociales en la
dirección que ven en sus pantallas y
para más información de nuestro
continente sigan viendo france24
[Música]